i'm going to admit something that i used  to dig holes in the dirt and stick my  dick in it i mean that's how i'll be  honest i don't think you've ever said  that on a podcast i'm really proud of  you i dug a hole in the earth  and i stuck my penis in it but i didn't  do it out of sexuality i did it out of  science i honestly thought if i came in  the earth you gross that it would grow a  bobby tree  bro  that is something a kid would believe  when you stuck your dick in the soil did  the other earth room say dad  that's not fair that my dick is as small  as the earth were skinny that was great  yeah yeah that was pretty good though  no the earthworm probably would say  what are you doing here  probably right you're an earthworm and  you're just squirming around in your  holes  and you look up and there's a yellow  dick  right  just in like right in front of you what  would you say you probably scream how do  you think earthworms scream  [Music]  alert